hi this is sal of of the khan academy
and you know we we've we've always had a
lot of content on khan academy for the
various ap tests and we've actually been
building out a lot for american history
so i'm here with kim who's our of
history or american history fellow and
what what what do you bring to the table
here kim did we just find you on the
street
no actually so i used to teach college
history for a number of years and last
year i actually graded the ap us history
exam so i have a pretty good insight
into what the graders are looking for
when you're
looking at the test
and and what we're hoping to do you know
we did a ap review for uh calculus a
couple days ago and it seemed to be
really successful so we thought it would
do today but this is still a little bit
groundbreaking and we're still figuring
it out just in terms of how to do these
live streams so give us your feedback
give us your questions on the the
comment thread uh below this is pretty
exciting you're i think you're part of
the first ever
live streaming ap american history
review session yeah in like in all of
history
so this is a historical one they make
our timeline of major points in american
history
the live stream
so
what what what i guess there's a bunch
of ways we can tackle this we have some
stuff here it looks like you've made a
timeline of all of american history this
is my beautiful timeline
and so maybe we could first go through
just a quick overview of it just so
everyone here including myself has
context and then uh you've put together
a pretty neat i would say kind of
high-level study guide that has the
different periods as well as the
different um
themes that the ap american history test
cares about so we've uploaded a
screenshot of this to facebook so you
can take a look at it yourself
but basically what we're doing here is
taking kind of the thousand-yard view of
american history and examining these
themes like migration and labor over
time to kind of get you a sense of how
things are moving that will help you
build intuition about what's going on in
a particular moment in american history
and not only will this help i think
everyone understand the layers of
american history but these are often
just even called out on the essay
portion of the exam or even even the
multiple choice yeah absolutely so this
will kind of build that backbone for you
so that when you're sitting down to
answer an essay question sitting down to
write a multiple choice question you can
say what was going on in american
culture in the early 1900s oh yeah this
was the jazz age this was you know a
period of internationalism nationalism
right so awesome awesome well let's get
i know uh people are watching from home
uh who probably can't read this when i'm
just holding it up like this but you
it's available for download
yeah we'll make that more obvious if
it's not already so so let's get started
let's let's do a uh a walk through what
400 no 600 years of history yeah it's
600 and that's not counting multiple
times we're going to try to do seven
times
yeah so that's not counting like 15 000
years ago when people actually crossed
the bering land bridge into what
continent existed
america so we're kind of we're skipping
forward in time to say
there were many native peoples who were
living on the american content continent
in 1492 which was this moment of contact
between europeans and native americans
you have it right there and then we see
that uh you have the contact but then
what's the significance of jamestown why
does this make this timeline right so
the first kind of hundred years of
settlement on the north american
continent is like the spanish they're
trying to just mine things they're
traders so these are people who are
taking resources from the new world and
bringing it back to the old they have no
intention of staying it's when we get to
jamestown and plymouth rock and
massachusetts bay this is when english
settlers are coming to what will be the
united states and planning on living
there i see so this is your first i mean
you're in america roanoke and all this
moves of course permanent first
permanent settlement first permanent
settlement what would be the united
states and that's a little after 1600
1608 or something like that but and then
and then you get to kind of the
formation of of the country what's going
on in this kind of the this really 200
year period so that's kind of what we
would call the colonial period and this
is when
there are various colonies we've got
massachusetts and virginia and georgia
and pennsylvania who are all pretty much
doing their own thing and they're mostly
focused on trade and farming
commerce and they don't really see
themselves as being even really part of
a nation or really anything other than
british subjects who are on the wrong
side of an ocean it's kind of in this
mid 1700s period when the british empire
starts really paying attention to the
colonies they're saying wait a minute
aren't you supposed to be helping us out
economically why can't why aren't we
taxing you more why don't they start
paying attention just they got big
enough and there's enough people there
and their economies were large enough to
matter yeah that and there's an economic
depression in in england they have a lot
of debt that they want to pay off so
they look across the ocean and say
we have a lot of people over there that
we could be making more money off of um
and
for the american colonists who are very
used to british british power being
super hands off this is
not okay with them at all they didn't
want that money just to kind of provide
benefits to the english citizens this
was during an age of empire or really
you know we're competing with the french
spanish
so there's this seven years war also
known as the french and indian war where
the american colonists and
the british are fighting against the
french and their native american allies
and this uh eventually the british
succeed and the colonists succeed but
now england's in a lot of debt they want
to tax the colonists to make up that
debt and the colonists are saying oh we
already helped enough right we actually
provided some manpower to do this
fighting so that's when they start
really rebelling against british
taxation and not to dig too deep we're
trying to do a fast but i always find it
fun you know seven years when i learned
in american history like oh the seven
years war or
but or
the french indian war but as you said
seven years ago it's part of a larger
theater it wasn't just in the us it's a
yeah this is a global war and it's hard
for us to see this but this is you know
these empires all over the world who are
competing for territory and resources so
you know this is just one small part of
a much larger war over empire wow very
and then that kind of attentions build
and
revolution
as far as revolutions go the american
revolution is maybe a boring one right
and this is a revolution over taxes
but
it's got this sort of revolutionary idea
of
these enlightenment thinkers oh i see
because you're saying it's economic
right but then there's principles
underlying that right so the principles
of you know
uh
consent of the govern is where you know
government draws its power instead of
absolute monarchy you know this is kind
of the birth of true democracy in the
united states it's going to really
spread throughout the world these the
ideas from the revolution go many places
in the world and it's a successful
revolution and and it's you i mean it is
unique and it inspires the french
revolution in certain ways and and so
now you have this you know you and
the revolution 1776 you have the
declaration of independence but it isn't
until the early 18th or late 18th 18th
oh sorry the late 17th yeah there we go
that you you have the the constitution
as we know it right and so the
constitution is kind of the blueprint of
american government so before that there
was the articles of confederation which
was a very weak government system
you know they had just fought against
this tyrannical power abroad and they
were saying all right well we're going
to make sure that we don't have a
central government that is going to be
tyrannical at home
unfortunately
that meant that their government
couldn't do anything
so the constitution is kind of this
amendment saying okay we are going to
organize our government into a judicial
executive and legislative branch
it was completely a redo it was
completely yeah um and they basically
built the system of government with its
checks and balances that we still have
today yep and so where this new country
the at the you know all pretty close to
the turn of the century
now we get into the 1800s yeah and so
the 1800s for the united states is
really this period of expansion both
sort of expansion of markets expansion
of technology and literal territorial
expansion
so um early on there's kind of the war
of 1812 which we call maybe revolution
part two british leave us alone really
we meant it
um
followed by what was the british work i
mean they it was another they were they
were back
what was their what was the the factor
that brought them
back oh well they never really left
actually here we go yeah they're up in
canada they're in the great lakes and
what really led the united states to to
declare war on england is the
impressment of american soldiers which
are sailors which meant that
uh british ships most powerful navy in
the world would be stopping american
ships and saying hey all you americans
you must be british sailors who
jumped ship you belong to us now
so the american
government declares war and they kind of
get this this final go-ahead saying all
right england get out of our affairs
okay and so but the u.s wins again yes
uh and as we we're we're expanding
territorially but there's there's kind
of tensions building in line with that
expansion yeah and and the tension here
is the existence of slavery right uh
slavery
started in the united states back in the
1620s so this was kind of the shortly
after you know
shortly after january shortly after
jamestown so
enslaved people from africa and the west
indies are being brought to
what will become the united states and
later the united states
uh as laborers for cash crops so they're
working in cotton fields they're working
on tobacco
um and even though the american
revolution is built on this idea that
all men are created equal she'll draw a
parallel line to show this so roughly
here i mean all of this is you know
slavery
is
you know and
you know
yeah um
it they just really did not solve the
problem of of slavery
so you know to get the cooperation of
the southern states at the time
of the revolution they kind of punted on
this issue of slavery and they continue
throughout the founding documents are
very principled on
people being equal and life liberty all
that but yes it was kind of like okay
we'll not
dig in too deep what that means right
now just so we're unified exactly but
then as we added territory
why did this why was that why did that
become why did that somehow exacerbate
the issue as we added territory the
problem would be kind of the balance of
power in between the north and the south
so
the early stages of the united states
and we can take a look at our map yeah
yeah this is uh i'll see this is if we
can if we can do this
all right
all right this is a beautiful map that i
colored myself
we're scrapping here that's right
um
so you know when the united states
was founded so here are the 13 colonies
there in red and then with the treaty of
britain at the end of the american
revolution we get all this territory
these are already british territories
britain hangs out up here right yes and
way over there yes um but then as the
19th century wears on
first
jefferson acquires a whole bunch of
territory
in 1803 in the louisiana purchase i
always find that interesting because
it's often built as like deal of the
century but napoleon was in charge of
frank he's fighting these wars in here
and he was his navy was kind of being
defeated he's like well i can't protect
that anyway yeah so so he sells it off
and he gets a whole bunch of money to
help him
on the other continent um so we've got
this whole bunch of land and then with
the mexican war
all of this land and so you can see it
kind of goes
right over the boundary where slavery
existed in the south and this is kind of
the line of slavery here
um
and then you have a lot of videos on
this on khan academy for people want to
dig deeper and we do um
and then this is the free area up here
so
you know they had managed to keep their
representation in the federal government
relatively equal so they had you know 11
states that were free 11 states that
permitted slavery
and then as new states started to form
out of these territories that might
upset the apple cart upset the balance
of power so they just kind of because if
the if there were more free states in
congress they might be more likely to
abolish slavery or you know in general
pass laws that would be more uh
beneficial to people who weren't part of
the slave economy and this wasn't just
even a pr i mean i'm sure there were
people on both sides on like a principal
level like slavery is good or bad it was
also an economic i remember you told me
once you know lincoln's father was kind
of put out of business because you
couldn't compete with plantations right
so you know there are many
white people who are living in the north
who are living in the what's now the
midwest who you know they didn't have
any real um
moral opposition to slavery what they
wanted was to be able to move out to
this area and not have to compete with
someone maybe moving from here with a
hundred slaves who he doesn't have to
pay
you know how is this guy going to be
able to sell his grain
for
less than someone who's got free labor
um
yes and so you have this honorary
expansion most of this is the 1800 this
is the 1800s
manifest destiny right this is the era
of manifest destiny so
these um you know these tensions really
continue as they're trying to balance
power and then you know in the course of
the 1850s there are more moral arguments
about slavery the abolitionists are
saying slavery is evil slavery is wrong
they're right we've got to end it now it
doesn't matter what's happening over
here
all slavery needs to go
and then there are sort of apologists
for slavery in the south who are saying
you know
slavery is a good thing you know we've
done so much for these people
uh and so you know there's just this
this true that's how you get up there's
a video you upload where you did it ap
american history and they had a passage
from one of these apologists so this
isn't you making it up i mean this was
actually
from from one of these people right
fascinating fascinating so this is the
1800s and and also i mean it's worth
noting the american indians were also
kind of being pushed back right i mean
and you know
the 1800s are you know just a
rotten century for native americans
maybe
not as rotten as kind of this period of
you know great death from disease that's
happening really early in contact but
this is a time when native american
lands just continue to shrink and shrink
and shrink and even native americans who
you know followed the rules they you
know assimilated they converted to
christianity found that they were still
forced out into farther and farther
western lands
because
whites wanted those lands
and this broader world context i mean
that also was where
the u.s started going from this kind of
agrarian to the industrial revolution
it's kind of an economic i mean an
economic power yeah you can start to
rival the powers of europe yeah and i
think that's a good sort of takeaway for
the era after the civil war so we
we have this great conflict of the civil
war yeah the powder keg
ignites right right there and you know
1861 to 1865 and the north
the the free
part of the united states prevails so
slavery is over and there's this kind of
brief period in the south where african
americans have
guaranteed civil rights basically
they've got a military they're
protecting their civil rights
and then at the end of reconstruction in
the north kind of gives up on protecting
them and so that starts the era of jim
crow
it's kind of an occupied territory
until that point yeah and so this is
where you have jim crow beginning
and what is jim crow you always hear
that word
so jim crow was a
uh no no just just crow like the bird um
it was a system of segregation so de
jure segregation or segregation by law
that said that
uh you know you it was legal for whites
and blacks to be in separate places so
this is the idea of separate but equal
that comes up in the late 19th century
saying that it is perfectly fine to send
black children only to black schools
it's perfectly fine to send white
children only to white stuff it's
developing and then there's barriers to
voting exactly and things like that and
that continues all the way to the next
maybe i'll do jim crow in a slightly
different color but you know that that
continues all the way until
you know yeah
some some something like that that's jim
crow right over right over there and as
you said and this is this coincides with
the industrial revolution the us really
getting its footing as a as maybe people
didn't realize it but it was it was
quietly becoming a world power exactly
and you know part of that power it
wasn't like on the world stage
right so
the north went to all this industrial
production to win the civil war and then
they have all these factories what are
they going to do with them they're going
to build stuff specifically steel for
railroads and so really by 1900 the
united states is the world's leading
industrial power we make more stuff than
anybody else
and then that gives us and we start
flexing that power a little bit you get
the spanish-american war right at around
the same time going into the turn of the
century and that's a war an imperial war
against spain uh which the united states
is basically looking to flex its muscles
saying we've got this big navy
we're super wealthy we've got great
industry
let's let everybody know what was the
what was the given cause and what what
is the actual cause uh the given cause
was that the spanish in cuba were
oppressing the cubans who were rebelling
against uh spanish rule and then when
the united states sent a ship down there
to protect american interests that ship
the uss maine exploded in havana harbor
that's probably a boiler malfunction uh
but the united states said oh no they
totally blew it up the spanish sabotaged
our ship so they went to war
uh they won easily i would say
on ships are often used to justify war
only to later be found gulf of tonkin
revolution later on
so yeah after this the united states
becomes an empire they have islands in
the pacific islands in the caribbean uh
and those islands are places as far as
the philippines yeah
and there's no path to statehood for
those islands you know the united states
has never before taken territory they
never expected the people who lived
there to become citizens and that to
some degree is almost a definition of
empire exactly it's when you have
control over people who are not formal
members of your nation right and
contrast that with the american
revolution right
how much did the people in the united
states what would be the united states
like having a power across the ocean in
charge of them not at all so it's quite
a turnaround for the united states to
take on that role as the power across
the ocean to a people that isn't
self-governing yep yeah and so now we go
this is kind of more modern times and
this is where i mean just as a reminder
khan academy has a lot of content on
modern times you've done a lot on civil
rights i've worked on the world wars so
for anyone who wants you know deeper
context here uh go there we actually
have a lot on the revolutionary period
yeah we heard a lot from students when
we started this project saying you know
my teacher is trying so hard but she
can't get past 1945 or you know my
teacher slowed down we never got past
vietnam and so what we did was say let's
start there so if that's a place where
you're feeling less confident khan
academy has a ton of material in that
period just to help students who are
struggling with the later stages of
american history it's videos it's
exercises it's articles we actually have
a few overview videos of all of
americans you do although this we're
kind of making one as we speak right now
live
so we go into
world war one which once that wasn't
really an american war not really the
united
uh in states
and that's because uh the germans
continued to attack u.s
ships in the atlantic yeah the lusitania
famously but this was i mean what
this is kind of when the u.s is like wow
they can tip the balance
yeah it shows that they're a real player
on the world stage and you know someone
like woodrow wilson tries to negotiate
what will become the league of nations
it's this first international
organization for keeping the peace which
clearly does not
work
and the united states never joins it uh
because there's this sort of
isolationist streak a lot of people said
oh man we should not have gotten
involved in world war one and we don't
want to we don't want to get involved in
another war if we commit to being part
of one of these international
peacekeeping organizations yeah the u.s
is still kind of not not fully
uh you know wants to be out there the
world's policemen so to speak yeah and i
mean they have an ocean in between them
and a lot of those problems which has
worked out pretty well for them up until
this point you have the space to develop
without having to fight wars all the
time absolutely absolutely and so we go
into that post-war period and how do you
describe the the 20s right before we get
into the stock market crash well the 20s
are kind of this era of consumerism
right this is when we've got all sorts
of cool new gadgets like
radios and cars and people are buying
them on credit um so there's this
massive expansion of american
consumerism and also american dabbling
in the stock market you know that was
not something that an ordinary person
did before the 1920s it seemed like a
really fun game
uh right up until it
didn't seem like until it crashed and
you get the crash
and then we're in the depression the
great depression yeah so the great
depression wasn't the first impression
we talked a lot about it's the most
recent big depression yeah uh you know
the economics of the united states since
the development of american economy have
always kind of been on this like 20-year
cycle of boom and bust and there are a
whole bunch of other panic of 1837 panic
of 1819 panic of you know there's a
panic every 20 years when there's a
bubble that bursts
but no bubble burst as badly as
the bubble of the 1920s great depression
and how
what effect did that have on like just
the country it was just a bad time and
we got out of it or has it somehow
changed the fabric of
oh yeah well i mean this was really the
the birth of the federal government
having an idea that they have a
responsibility for citizens welfare
right i mean for most of american
history
the biggest influence the federal
government had on your life was the post
office like that's the only time you saw
the federal government and then started
which is one of the themes we'll talk
more about that the us has always been
very much a
both individualistic but also
kind of states
have a it's
very decentralized yes people have been
very suspicious of the central
government central government yeah so i
mean
really that's it the post office until
the civil war when you know lincoln
expands a lot of federal power and
institutes a draft for the first time
but it wasn't until the great depression
that the federal government said it's up
to us to make sure that our citizens
aren't starving in this in the street
it's up to us to make sure that when
you're old you know you can still live
well when you're not able to work
anymore so that's kind of the
expansion of what we call the the social
welfare state and fdr shows up and he's
kind of you know when people talk about
keynesian economics he used it
on a massive scale building dams and i
mean some of it was you know to actually
provide energy and all this but also
the theory is to jump start the economy
to utilize all that excess capacity to
get the
and and that kind of starts out you have
fdr but then it really the pressure ends
with with world war ii yeah clearly we
weren't all done in europe with world
war one no um and world war ii you know
the united states had continued to be
very isolationist throughout the 1930s
their idea was we've got enough problems
um
so they really tried not to get involved
in world war ii as it was beginning in
europe but then
in 1941 the japanese
bombed pearl harbor and so the united
states
joined this this world war that was
already going the japanese had invaded
china
in the late 30s or actually in the early
30s and then you have you know the the
germans that had invaded poland right
well before the us joined in the war the
germans and the japanese are allied so
after the
the japanese bombed pearl harbor the
germans actually uh
proactively declared war on the united
states we might not actually have gone
into a war
with germany had not
the ally of japan already declared war
on us yeah and it's unlikely to be
deeply covered on the ap american
history exam but since these were major
things for the u.s it was because a lot
of people cite reparations and the
treaty of versailles and germany kind of
so you have a demagogue like hitler
comes to power and tries to kind of get
that german pride going and
builds this war machine
that is got awfully close
scarily close yes so then world war ii
ends and so how how is the u.s relative
to the rest of the world after world war
ii well the united states kind of comes
out of world war ii remember they're on
the other side of an ocean so they're
pretty much the only nation in the world
whose industrial capacity is still
functioning right the united states
didn't get bombs during world war ii
yeah the other great industrial powers
you're talking about germany
england or uk france japan
they got their factories were yeah it's
gonna take them a long time to rebuild
from that so the united states really
emerges as the world's preeminent
industrial power they're supplying
stuff to everyone
and then they're in sort of a political
standoff with the soviet union
over
basically what economic and political
form the world should take
yeah you have bretton woods and they
create this kind of economic world order
because they're competing against
communism right so they want that to win
anyone who's aligned with them has a
better economy and then obviously also
like political and and and military uh
escalation and then that goes all the
way until
you have vietnam which is what's notable
about vietnam here i guess it was the
you could say the hottest part of the
cold war yeah definitely maybe some of
the things in the 60s bay of pigs and
cuban missile crisis got pretty hot so
the cold war never involves an actual
war between the united states and russia
they never actually you know are
fighting against each other directly
instead it involves a bunch of proxy
wars or wars where the united states is
supporting one side usually the side
that is associated with capitalism
and the united the ussr is supporting
the other side that is associated with
communism so there's this sort of
nationalist uh fight what we call sort
of a civil war in vietnam where northern
vietnam which was communists
wanted to unite all of vietnam under
communism and south vietnam had the
united states help in kind of staving
that off and this is
it's fascinating how history all
injuries because
vietnam was a french colony
during world war ii
the french get overrun by the british
and so then the japanese
and so and so you're left with that and
so there's kind of a power vacuum after
world war ii
and so you have these different powers
start to take hold but then when you
have you know communist china on to the
north right and now us and you have
george cannon and containment and we
have a lot once again content
on this uh you put nixon resigning why
is that notable you know we only list
about 15 or 20 things here why is that
in 400 years of american history
maybe it doesn't deserve to be there i
don't know but it's interesting you know
nixon um
was the last president during vietnam
and he says he's going to get the united
states out of vietnam this was on both
parties i mean vietnam
kennedy is a democrat starts getting
involved yeah then you have
johnson really escalates right i mean
being pro-communist was not a political
position in the united states or
anti-communist or whatever right so yeah
both democrats and republicans and then
nixon comes in and everyone's saying
that they want to
take us out it's not a popular war yeah
especially later on but then they can't
help but getting further and further
sucked in pretty much so nixon presides
over this the war is kind of winding
down
and then um it comes out that nixon has
kind of worked to
undermine the democratic process by
spying on his famous watergate yeah
watergate institute in the office
building yeah
so this is real kind of a black mark on
american democracy but not the first i
mean so sometimes we think modern times
things politics have gotten ugly and all
of that but as you decided also the
videos are kind of
similar
politics has always been ugly but then
we go the cold war ends that's
definitely a big deal yeah
the end of the 1980s early 1990s the
soviet union collapses uh and you can
kind of debate how much the united
states played a role in that
most historians think that
it wasn't very much i mean you know it
was economical you know some would argue
this arms race that you know reagan's
helped accelerate really broke you know
our economy could could somehow survive
that better than the soviet economy
could well capitalism clearly
provided a better way of life than
communism um but the soviet union kind
of fell apart under the weight of its
own problems i would say so by you know
the united states is the world's
remaining superpower and that's
essentially the world we live in today
where you don't have this kind of you
know two powers you have the united
states as a superpower
and you have the smaller conflicts and
frankly more complex in a lot of ways
fascinating so actually our timer is
went to sleep
we are on time okay all
right half an hour so that was cool
let's let's talk a little bit about some
of these themes here and we probably
touch on stuff we already talked about
but just to reinforce it so these are
the themes that come from the ap exactly
it's like these layers of american
history so the first one is american
national identity so we talked a lot
about that yes exactly so this is this
kind of uh what does it mean to be an
american who is an american and how does
that change over here it's the native
americans exactly and then and you have
explorers kind of showing up for
discovery or looking for gold yeah and
none of them are thankful i'm an
american right they're thinking i'm
spanish and i'm going to go home with
all my gold and live like a king yeah
and then you have english settlers and
what actually i mean why would you want
to get on a boat and go
you know 3 000 miles
and live in you know
some places for some people it was it
was money um for other people economic
land if you if you're kind of a surf
essentially a surf in england yeah
england has a real overpopulation
problem at this time period so there is
a lot of poverty there and this
getting a little religious freedom yeah
the pilgrims and whoever else they
wanted to come and these people tend to
be more conservative religiously and
they were somewhat ostracized in england
yes yes this is the puritans that we're
talking about and this is a branch of
protestant christianity which is very
strict um so they are they're not
popular in england because the anglican
church uh it's not as strict
was in the ascendancy you know
associated with the the royal family uh
so they can either be persecuted in
england or they can just give up and go
to a new world and make a society that
fits with their standards yeah yeah and
so that's starting to be you know you
start having the the settlements in
english settlements we think of you know
the us current u.s and then uh but at
this point people you know in the 1700s
people consider themselves english
citizens consider themselves english
citizens or maybe pennsylvanians or
south carolinians they don't have a
strong american identity
and then as we go
through the revolution now the identity
starts building right and so they they
have this sort of common cause against
the british empire saying well maybe we
need to join or die right as as ben
franklin uh wrote and
kind of develop an american spirit that
will help defeat the british and make
the united states
highlighted even at this point it was
white males right and not just white
males but wealthy white males who own
land and this is who an american citizen
is you know when jefferson is
considering you know who do i want to
vote in this new republic he's not
thanking everybody he is thinking the
wealthiest best educated landowners who
have that specific stake in the american
i think it's important mean we talk a
lot about things like slavery but i mean
women weren't
participants in this i would put that on
your timeline yeah next we'll do that
wonder woman vote women don't vote until
1920. yes you see
i'm sorry it was more important than
nixon resigning
so this is
this is world war one
right about there yeah it's around here
okay
so this is a long time that's not even
100 years ago i know so anyway back to
this so right here it's it's it's white
landlording men was a lot of maybe what
some of you some of the founding fathers
were thinking yeah not all of them but
some of them uh but then it starts
getting a little bit broader yeah so if
you think about american national
identity in this this first part of the
19th century i think you can think about
it first as democracy expanding because
by the time jackson is present in the
1820s 1830s
the american
electorate expanded to all white men
so you didn't have to own property you
know you could be
anyone who is fits the bill of white and
mail
and cast a vote
but there's also this kind of growing
sectional identity right if you're
thinking about yourself as an american
you're probably thinking of yourself
also as a northerner or a southerner
early 1800s very strong sort of
sectional division as far as identity
goes and does that change with the civil
war
sort of i mean you know the the version
of america where slavery is illegal
prevails um so i think that's part of
the the national identity at that point
it starts to shift at least on paper
african americans are allowed to vote
right after males yes are allowed to
vote yeah and this is another moment for
women's rights because the 15th
amendment grants the right to vote to
african american men and you know they
were already making an amendment to the
constitution so a lot of women's rights
activists said all right it starts to
really become an active lady yeah well
let's let's add women's rights to the
15th amendment and they didn't get it
fascinating and so then we get
we're so we're getting to this period uh
african-americans become
more citizens although right you know
depends where they live and probably
their economic situation and things like
that and so
what what is kind of you know we talked
about the european immigration
and this you know in this period up here
would be primarily english right when
did it start becoming from other parts
of europe well we would start kind of
around 1840 which is the irish potato
famine so there are just
thousands upon thousands of irish people
who have given up in ireland they can't
eat and so they're coming to the united
states for a new way of life there are
also uh political revolutions
revolutions of 1848
in
europe that are driving lots of other
europeans especially germans to the
united states
so that kind of goes on into the 1870s
1880s and then we have a huge wave of
immigration from southern and eastern
europe so this is in in italy in russia
what is that roughly that's at the
that's the end of the 19th century so
1880s 18. and this is this coincides
with the industrialization exactly so
they're looking for jobs you know and
you read these books uh like upton
sinclair and all these folks that are
you know they're working in the
factories maybe under sub-optimal
conditions
and but they're coming here for a better
life yeah and i think what one thing
that's interesting about this is because
you know we have a definition of
whiteness today that is very much based
on skin color right you look white
you're white but they had a much
different idea of who was white who was
an american citizen because originally
they thought irish people were
really considered not white enough and
then later on they say oh well someone
from italy someone from russia
they're too different from anglo-saxons
to be considered white so even though
they have some political rights they can
vote
they're not really considered part of
the american body politic like someone
whose ancestry is english might be
not really until i would say world war
ii
yeah i mean even you know even in the in
the 20th century
you know it was a big deal i mean people
it was a big deal john kennedy was
catholic right absolutely yeah because
he was kind of
you know yeah irish or you know the
catholics were irish or italians or
and so this was a big deal and he was
not protestant yeah and there's strong
ethnic communities too this is why you
have you know little italy and um
you know polish brotherhoods as
these ethnic groups grew in american
cities and then starting around world
war ii these men all kind of get sent to
the war together they develop more bonds
and after world war ii including african
america i mean african americans part of
the civil war on the revolutionary war
yeah absolutely but but it becomes
people start to identify as a nation
versus language
i mean english is the language but
around ethnicity
yeah and i mean if you if there's one
thing that brings people together it's
having a common enemy yes
so you know the idea we're american you
know we're not german we're not japanese
these these ideas really coalesce in
world war ii to bring national identity
more about being from the united states
than having a specific racial identity
yeah and so now you have
after world war one in the 20s women
become participants
at least as voters it takes a little
while for them to get positions of power
exactly one position of power
maybe might happen
soon but but that's when they get
involved and so
kind of those trends would you say they
kind of go through world war ii
exactly and then how would you say that
they've changed since then well i think
the civil rights movement is one of the
most important sort of
political and cultural movements yeah to
come out of world war ii
which is
you know think about being an
african-american soldier in world war ii
and you're in france and then having to
listen to someone say the united states
is the you know the location where
democracy is true and every man is
created equal and you're thinking hmm
yeah that's not been my experience or if
you're a second or third generation
japanese you know your grandfather
immigrated from japan to help build the
railroads and your family's an
internment camp while you're fighting
exactly
so you know they a lot of
african-american veterans come home and
they say all right we listen to all this
propaganda abroad i think you know if we
learned anything it's how important
voting is so they really begin the civil
rights movement which is a national
movement in the south and the north to
first secure voting rights for african
americans and then they're sort of a
more generalized movement for you know
housing rights and poverty that kind of
work toward a more inclusive idea of
american citizenship and it's really
interesting because i mean this is not
going to be on the ap american history
exam but it's always worth citing i was
pointed out because there weren't a lot
of other non-white people here
then
for example people from south asia or or
or and and
that they
that was a civil rights movement frankly
for all of us
because if that didn't happen then you
would have had segregation i mean
yeah more broadly and the civil rights
movement also inspires future social
reform movements so in the late 60s and
70s there's the women's rights movement
that said you know women shouldn't just
be able to vote they should also be able
to hold the same jobs as men and be paid
equally or the
lgbtq movements also pattern on on the
civil rights saying
we're going to use the same tactics of
protest uh and you know
advertisement of what's going on to try
to change ourselves and you have figures
like martin luther king inspired by
gandhi who was revolutionary in india
during you know in the lead up to
to world war world war ii so let's let's
go let's go through more of these themes
politics and power
all right this one is a little bit more
uh specific i would say just because
we're talking about maybe who gets to
rule right who is in power yeah so i
would say like this early period here
it's all about the spanish yeah right i
mean the spanish set up this sort of
system of slavery basically to try to
extract wealth
yeah the best political tool up here was
probably the gun
i would say probably the microbe would
be the microbe unfortunately
and then there's kind of a i would say a
difference again between the north and
the south for what political power
looked like you know in the north they
kind of set up a very democratic system
right they're they're small farmers
they're living in small towns so they
have town hall meetings and kind of
decide things pretty democratically
i mean there's there's religion and
religion plays a really central role in
what's important and and who gets power
in the north but in the south there's a
system of slavery right and so there are
these landowners who have
thousands of acres of land and they
really hold all the wealth and the
political power so even the democratic
institutions of the south like the
virginia house of burgesses
are based on the wealth generated by
slavery
fascinating and and that continues and
obviously the power of politics i mean
we talked about the into the civil war
yeah and i mean we can also talk about
sort of the democratic and
the political parties that arise in the
early part of the united states so what
were the political parties in your early
part so at first and what washington
warned us against parties washington
washington was not a fan of political
parties um that's strange most of us
love them
what could be better than a party it's
gonna be terrible because it's just
going to make us yell at each other all
the time and he was not wrong about that
but the original parties were divided on
this
concept of whether power should be
centralized in the united states or
whether it should be diffused to the
states so the federalist party was all
about central power they wanted a strong
central government they wanted a
national bank yeah they wanted lots of
development
and then the anti-federalists
uh or we often call them um
democratic republicans
were kind of the opposite of that is
there a house in there yeah
um
they wanted the states to have most
power they wanted a pretty small central
government we mostly associate
federalists with alexander hamilton john
adams
and then the anti-federalists the their
real standard bearer was thomas
jefferson yeah and if anyone has extra
time while they're preparing i highly
recommend the don quincy adams what is
it like a six or seven part oh john
adams john adams
not quincy adams yeah that's a great yes
that is really it's very inspiring so we
start out with a federalists um with
john adams and then in 1800 i think this
is one of the most important political
dates
of the united states march 3rd i think
that's the right day 1800 do you know
what happened
march 3rd 1800
that's so what you have uh jefferson
versus no i don't what happened on that
day nothing nothing
nothing happened because there was a
question transfer of power oh from one
political power from one political party
to another and that is basically unheard
of can you imagine voluntarily giving up
power
in this sort of monarchy as recent
nation-building experiments have shown
that that doesn't happen
normally yeah
so the anti-federalists are pretty much
more or less in power um
up until
the um the slavery debate kind of
becomes even bigger and then
the federalists kind of die off because
they were against the war of 1812. okay
nobody likes a hater so
um
the the wig party kind of takes over
what are the wigs i always read what are
they what do they represent
the wigs uh abraham lincoln was a wig uh
before he became a republican and the
wigs were pretty much for they were for
development they were pro railroad pro
canal and who are the whigs going
against they're going against the the
jacksonian democrats who are kind of the
the heirs to the anti-federalists so you
know just as jefferson had only imagined
democracy for wealthy white landowners
and then jackson said there should be
universal white male suffrage
his version of this sort of
anti-centralization
like if i was a business owner at this
period i'd probably be awake you'd
probably be a wig if you were a small
farm around the west you'd probably be a
democrat and and in terms of the slavery
issue the wigs are worthless
generally anti-slavery slavery they're
often sort of northeasterners they're
generally very religious
and then jacksonian democrats were
generally pro-slavery and so when do we
get into a kind of our modern period of
parties well i would say that this
democratic party is still the democratic
party that we have today
and you know as we've gone through the
years and we've changed different issues
you know what they stand for changes um
and then in the late 1850s the
republican party was born
the republican party was an anti-slavery
party
the whigs kind of fell apart
in the
late
1840s i think is correct um
and were replaced by the republicans who
had many of the same values but were
specifically anti-slavery yeah this was
more like these were sympathetic to the
anti-slavery this was almost formed
around the anti-slavery exactly
and lincoln gets elected as the first
republican president he's the first
republican and so that was the spark as
we as we've done in several videos where
we talk about it together
yeah and so the republicans pretty much
stay in power up until world war one
that's when uh wilson gets elected he's
the first democrat to serve um
i believe in between the civil war and
world war one so that's a long period
and this you know this is the the
business interest party which is going
to do very well in this time yes okay so
you have a problem yeah this period of
industrialization that's the gilded age
that's when you know you have the
carnegies and the you know so so okay
and so that period and you see the swing
back and forth in american history
exactly between i mean this goes back to
this politics and power theme right that
you know sometimes it's like the you
know the jacksonian democrats the
everyman very populist and then it's
it's 10 minutes oh 10 minutes left 10
minutes we could go a little lower
this is fun trying to go faster you have
these you have these swings and you have
these swings between you know kind of
the ever you know the common man and
more populist movements uh and uh maybe
more business interests or economic
growth yeah sometimes they'll say you
know the
system isn't democratic enough and then
they'll say oh maybe the system's a
little too democratic
um so the republicans except for this
this moment with wilson are in power
until the stock market crash right this
is a big
uh hit for business yeah and then you
have fdr coming in who maybe defines the
modern democratic party yeah exactly you
know this is a new deal this period of
increased government
uh work towards social welfare
and
the democrats who you know want to spend
money on social problem problems
on social movements in general they
pretty much stay in power until nixon
so there's a 30-year
period where the democrats are really
defining world
u.s politics it seems like something's
in the air right now but it's fun to
connect with i mean you seem like you
have what parties stand for
transitioning a little bit right now
yeah and i mean after that we we
generally think of the modern era as
being more conservative than this era
that came before it right this is the
time when labor unions are really strong
and you know the government is spending
a lot of money on social programs and
kind of starting in the 1980s there's
been a little bit of a
walk away from and you have a little bit
of a flip-flop between the parties
where
the you have the the republicans are a
little are a little bit more
sympathetic to
uh or the civil rights movement is gets
a little bit more sympathy from you know
johnsons of the world from from the
democrats yeah this is a little bit
confusing because the there is a sort of
a flip-flop of the demo of the parties
especially the democratic party yeah the
business interests
the business of economic growth and
business that's kind of consistent with
the founding of the republican party
right but the democrats really used to
be the party of slavery and later the
party of jim crow with the great
depression and then later the civil
rights movement the democrats said you
know if we want to get the economy back
on track we're really going to need to
use this federal money
and later said
you know uh we should continue i gave a
lot of power to the federal government i
mean just going back to that whole
you know states rights i mean fdr
expansion of the federal government too
yeah which was uh so fascinating we
could we could we have many videos on
this it's uh so let's i mean we could do
a couple things more of these things we
could tackle a couple of questions do
you to do that oh
what do you want to think so there's
been a couple interesting questions that
have come up okay
a couple of students are nervous about
the long essay question oh okay
synthetic
sure the the question is how do we
approach the long essay uh and just
synthesis as a general skill uh and we
have a sample long essay question if you
want us to work on through that yeah
right
we're not going to write it we will
speak to what could be written all right
this one right here yeah the revolution
one all right all right let's tape this
one up
you're going to have to
use your own counsel on migration and
culture and society yeah well we're
going to make this available so people
can and and i i suggest everyone to take
a look at these uh i mean kim's done an
incredible job here because this really
talks about all of the major themes that
and these actually would be really good
points to even bring up in the essay
portion so really encourage you to take
a good look at this yeah and i'm around
you know i answer questions on khan
academy i answer questions on youtube so
and facebook so yeah if you have any
other questions for us just let me know
awesome so let's read this some
historians have argued that the american
revolution was not revolutionary in
nature
support modify or refute this
interpretation providing specific
evidence to justify your answer
so what would you do kim when you see
that you have this blank space to fill
up
so i think um
all of the essay questions are kind of
going to be like this you know do you
support modify or refute this
interpretation
so we have we have three ways we could
go with this right we can say support it
the american revolution was not
revolutionary we could say refute it i
want to refute it yeah the american
revolution was super revolutionary
or refute would be like or modify this
is yeah
uh this is a
a terrible question here's the right
question that's a little harder to do i
don't know i i can't think of something
off the top of my head that would do
that yeah so support was like no it
wasn't revolutionary modified it was
like it was revolution in some respects
but maybe not in other respects were a
few i know it was actually quite
revolutionary exactly yeah so you would
have a pen like a marker and sharpie
yeah yeah okay so so but just a
high-level thinking so
just you for you personally where do you
fit on this stuff
my gut when i even read this like no it
is revolutionary i would totally go the
other way maybe i'm a negative and
either one would be okay as long as we
back up our as our points well
so yeah i would say so the question that
they're asking here for us is
is a society before
very different than the society after
1776 or after 1783
right
so there are various things that we
could think about here we can think
about uh politics right we just have
been going through these themes like is
the political system different we could
think about society you know uh our
social roles economics yeah we can think
about economics
geopolitics yeah um
or military or
yeah uh so do all the same things of
those
so
about geopolitics or culture would be
another i don't know how you can think
it wasn't revolutionary
i mean let's spook it out okay politics
politics yeah i mean yeah the england at
the time had some had a parliament and
stuff but it was still you know they had
a king on their money and they but now
you had you know you had thomas paine
and the rights of man and you have
and you have this little you know this
colony and they're taking on the most
powerful military in in in in or navy
for sure pride military in the world and
they're able to win and they and it's
all about rule by the individual and and
these these these ideas that they
resurfaced and in a lot of ways
perfected from the greeks and the romans
come back but thousands of years like
you know what
roughly 1500 2 000 years later this is
great because okay so you're now doing
like the pro-revolutionary side and that
gives you the anti-revolutionary side
i'm going to say that the revolution
wasn't that revolutionary politically
because the same people who were in
power in the united states before the
revolution were the people who were in
power after the road right after the
revolution but i would make that
argument that sure like the year after
yeah like
but this revolution and just so you know
we did not prepare this
it's completely improv right now but
these ideas
are allowed when allowed over the next
few hundred years all of this other
stuff to happen you are making precisely
gordon wood's argument yes you know
so you were like brainstorming gordon
wood right now yeah well it's it's true
but but
you know when i think of the revolution
yeah the next day might have not changed
but this was the spark
yes and actually almost immediately of
the french revolution which didn't
immediately you know
it became somewhat tyrannical with
napoleon and all of that actually even
before napoleon but it did spark this in
modern times the spread of democracy
what we now take for granted
constitutional democracies
this was it that's that's a revolution
all right well then real me this gordon
wood how different was american society
after 1776 than it was before well not
right after okay
right after but once again because if
the revolution didn't happen then once
again you wouldn't have been able to
have all of these
not only do you have a democracy but
this even goes to economics
if the revolution didn't happen you
would have had the big power england
have all of this extra industrial might
and all this extra agricultural land but
now you had an economic power that was
growing in the next hundred years that
was also a
democracy and so that combination
and so you know
when you have a superpower here that's
you know it's it's imperfect there's you
know there's some parts that look a
little bit hypocritical but for the most
part it was true to
to the you know the tenants and it
became more and more true over time it's
continuing to all right so you're saying
in the long term these social values
came to pass i'm going to say in the
short term
i mean how can you have a revolution
that says all men are created equal
and not
and still have slavery
right yes it was it was definitely not i
mean revolutions are never in fact by
definition i mean can you you can't
point to a revolution that's like clean
that like you know people storm the
whatever and then you know
they put the king out of rule and then
the next day everything's hunky-dory
revolutions are all i i know maybe you
know more history than i do but from
what i know they're always messy and
there's always a period where
people are fighting and a lot of the
people who had power before still have
power
but they they start an interesting
conversation yeah but does that last for
like 87 years four score and seven years
of slavery after the revolution
i guess yes
all right how about economics
economics economic revolution that i
would not say so much
that's not that's not yeah i mean for
example if you were to compare and that
could be like a modifier and that's
maybe a point to bring up is in the
1800s economically the u.s and england
were in some ways very similar you know
they're developed they're part of the
industrial revolution they were
so if they were the same country
not unclear if they were
that fundamentally different all right
well i'm going to take the international
view now and say in terms of revolutions
if you compare the american revolution
and the french revolution
economically
i mean the french revolution was a
revolution of the people against
the uh the monarchy right against the
the wealthiest people well the united
states doesn't change anybody's real
no you're right
i agree with you this was not an
economic revolution yeah the echo i mean
you know kind of there were pocketbook
issues of taxation and representation it
was much more it was much more
philosophical it was economic at a for
everyone it wasn't one class versus
another class
while the french revolution was like
textbook
the class is fighting fighting it out
well i think i'm winning right now so
you're going to need to provide i don't
think i don't think i i really i think
you're very biased
in this in this um
so let's see
geographically
yeah it's unclear i i
i think i think by becoming a nation
the ideas of manifest destiny became you
know if you're part of the british
empire
you you would have
you know the sun never sets on the
british empire they were already in
india they were already in africa they
were you know they're
or starting to become be in africa
especially in the 1800s and so you know
there could have been argument that like
oh it was just an extension of this
already vast empire
while here it's like this notion of
manifest it's much more of a
nationalistic thing right so it causes
manifest destiny
yeah so it's a big
transformation of the american body
politics yeah yeah and i might make the
opposite argument that the american
revolution was terrible for native
americans right i mean the british were
the
major power that were defending the
rights of native americans that's why in
the war of 1812 native americans are
going to ally with the british
so wouldn't you argue i mean for better
for worse that would be an argument that
was a change yeah so
you could see it could go either way i
mean and actually
in a certain way slavery probably would
have ended sooner
yeah if if we stayed a british colony i
would say so because slavery was
outlawed in england before and so yeah
the way we're structuring you know
there's multiple ways to structure it is
how do the world been different if the
revolution happened which is actually a
fun thing i mean now that we're doing it
and i mean just to you know obviously if
we were taking the test we wouldn't
write it this way right you would write
it out a little bit but these are how
does it get you you you've graded these
things how does this get graded well i
would say that what you want to do here
is use each of these big themes as your
topic sentences
so maybe you know if i were doing
something like this i might just write
down some possible things i could talk
about right how does the economy change
how does the politics change and then
make notes and decide which side you
fall on and then use that as your thesis
statement right to say that oh the
american revolution was super
revolutionary because none of these
major social changes could have happened
down the line without it or the american
revolution wasn't revolutionary at all
because it changed nothing for actual
people who lived there
i stand still arguing for my services
and i mean this is why this framework is
really valid because right when i first
saw it i was like maybe i could write
like a sentence on this but then when
you when you start to say okay we could
talk about uh national identity which is
kind of culture
we could talk about politics and power
we could talk about work technology and
exchange and economics exactly we could
talk about cultural society migration
and settlement so when you have this
framework and you know if you just know
okay these are the dimensions i can talk
about on pretty much any essay statement
exactly then all of a sudden you have a
lot to write yeah consider these themes
whenever you're thinking about writing
an essay because they will kind of
illuminate things for you about
where things are changing and where
things are staying the same and the the
graders unlike you are fairly impartial
and they're not gonna
right because as long as you are making
a strong argument and you're providing
evidence
then they know that you're
you know think of them like a jury that
you're trying to convince if you're a
lawyer right you are
making an argument and saying here's why
i'm right and so what they're interested
is are you convincing them not are you
saying what i want you to say and how
much do things like grammar
and
you know you have to be understandable
be understandable yeah like spelling
grammar you don't ding i mean be
understandable
but this main is your ideas and i think
you know
when i took this exam
more years ago than i cared i took it
even more years ago
you know i had this idea that the
graders were like oh i'm looking for all
the things that they did wrong so i can
mark them down but having graded it
myself what i noticed was that we're
looking for opportunities to give people
points like the people who agreed this
exam they are ap us history teachers
they are college teachers and they want
you to succeed so they're actually on
your side so
as much as time allows keep writing yeah
because there's a lot to write about and
you know and make sure you give context
right like make sure you say who's doing
something when and why because for
example if you say like what's one one
thing that the europeans changed about
native american culture and you respond
disease
right there's not enough there for you
to say all right well we're gonna
disease and i actually don't know the
answer is i mean when i took it i wrote
it out but can you make a table
and write points on either side and then
refer to i mean is that recommended oh
yeah that's that's totally recommended
you get 35 minutes to do this question
and i would say absolutely use the first
five to ten minutes just to make some
notes and an outline for yourself but
even the table itself could be part of
your answer maybe not i mean i think
they're they're looking for the thesis
they're looking for the thesis statement
and the topic sentences definitely use
something like this just to structure it
just to yeah get your thoughts in order
all right
we have a couple more we're probably
close to out of time
multiple choice just for kicks if he
wants let's do one multiple choice
we're sticking around we're sticking
around
history for you i'm so worked up about
how you cannot think that that was a
revolution
i'm just devil's advocate yes
all right we'll do this one and then
call it a day
okay so this is a typical multiple
choice question for the ap exam and
all of these questions they have either
a set of quotes or a graph or a
political cartoon so they're never in
the void they're always asking you to
refer to refer to some information so
then there'll be like two to four
questions that are actually related to
okay so let's just try to do this okay
so
first let's actually look at our graph
yeah okay you look at the graph first i
read the question
okay
i will i will look at this graph while
you're reading this question the pattern
depicted on the graph and i have not
seen this question before
this is we're going to just give the raw
how do you do it let's see sal get this
wrong
the pattern depicted on the graph from
1450 to 1800
all right that's the years here best
serves as evidence of which of the
following now i'm going to look at the
graph before i look at the choices so
let's see number of africans transported
to the new world between 1450 and 1900
all right so those are our bounds and
then we see very few were transported
prior to 1600 which is consistent to
what you were saying it wasn't being
settled it was kind of exploration and
trying to get riches and stuff then you
have more than sixteen hundred and
seventy times you start having permanent
settlements right referencing i'm just
thinking what i just learned from you
yeah using the logic of the context
right yeah and then 1700s to 1800s you
have a that's the peak
of influx and this is the peak of kind
of i'm guessing yeah settlement of
creation plantations and um especially
in the south and then it dies off here
especially because
uh i mean actually before the civil war
the importation stop started to slow
down yeah and then after the civil war
was abolished so that's why you have
this okay so now i have i think i've
you've got the context yeah so the
pattern depiction on the graph from
145-1800 best serves as evidence of
which of the following the replacement
of indigenous labor and indentured
servitude by enslaved africans in new
world colonies no that just doesn't feel
right because
indigenous labor we didn't even talk
about indigenous labor as being a major
oh yeah
ah let's see
one thing i want to talk about
oh but indentured servitude yeah that's
interesting one thing i want to point
out here is that it says 1450 to 1800.
oh oh oh okay not including this
let me get this wrong let me get this
one okay
don't help me too much
the development of various systems of
racial categorization in the now this
doesn't refer to that at all
that's definitely i can rule that out
i'll i'll definitely rule that out
the effectiveness of the abolitionist
movement in europe and the americas so
that could speak to this but they're
saying between 1450 and 1800 so we're we
are not even looking we're not even
looking at this so if you just look at
that part you just see this upper trend
so that that doesn't apply any effect
yeah so let's cross that one out the
susceptibility of enslaved populations
and world diseases no this doesn't say
this doesn't say whether people survive
or not right we're not saying who's
coming so that's definitely not it and
so the thing that i was about to rule
out
because i was like indigenous labor
uh and i was i'm thinking more native
american labor which i i'm not aware of
being a major source of labor in
like mexico the spanish used a lot of
indigenous labor but okay it wasn't
right and this is to the new world
but you're right i mean we do read about
indentured servitude you get your trip
to the new world but you have to work
for seven years exactly et cetera et
cetera and but this is a good example
right because this is one where
a didn't jump out at me in fact when i
first read a i'm like yeah i don't
indigenous labor but then these other
three were way more wrong yes like the
the chart had very little to do with
them right and it's best serves as
evidence yeah so even if you're like meh
that's maybe not the greatest thing it's
better than all the other choices so
this is evidence that i'm doing this the
first time yes all right now i'm going
to do that i'm in the ap american
industry which of the following
contribute most directly to the change
in the number of africans transfer
transported to the new world after 1800
so now we're talking about what
contributed to the change we see this
downward delta
the emergence of a more industrial
economy in great britain and the united
states
so well i mean they're talking about
great britain we're talking about
transportation to the new contributor
mostly to change transport to the new
world so in great britain
industrialization i guess your less
these large agricultural plantations
okay i'll think about it the outlawing
of the international slave trade by
great britain in the united states that
seems interesting i'll i'll kind of you
know i'll i'll
star that one the increased resistance
to slavery within african nations
uh we didn't talk a lot about that uh
and i don't remember so i don't yeah
this one doesn't seem too right the
influence of major slave rebellions in
haiti and elsewhere um no there were
rebellions but that shouldn't impact the
overall um
so
and
and just having a more industrial
economy you still have large i mean
there's still a very agricultural
country at the time in the in the early
1800s so
you know that might have been more in
the north and that's why frankly they
were more on the abolitionist side so
yeah the outlying of the international
slave trade which makes sense yeah
you're right i'm right thank you
all right well we're we're all done
hopefully everyone enjoyed this any
parting thoughts for the test takers
don't stress right
the test is not designed for you to know
every little fact what it's designed to
do is to test your kind of historical
reasoning right do you have this general
overall sense of what's going on and
using that knowledge can you make an a
good guess
i didn't guess
you yes i deduced put on your answer
this is a deduction
can you deduce
the the correct answer so
you know
think about the large themes uh and
don't sweat the details
thank you thanks good luck